that trad wife to single mom in your 40s pipeline
yes that's being exposed
I am one of those 41 year old single mom to 4 kids that was once a trad wife
uh for 10 years
and now I'm one of those out here trying to get everybody to listen to me
warning them about what that lifestyle is like
the only correction I would say is not all of us get left
I am a single mom by choice
I realized what was happening because when you're in it
you can sense it
it's fun for the first couple of years
search cute oh yeah
the first few kids
but once real life gets at you and day to day is not Pinterest and you know
kids do a lot more crying than they do snuggling
and you realise how lonely it is and then you start to feel like a prop
like I feel like every woman knows the
the levels of feelings that you go through
not all of us just sit around and wait to get left
I did not single mom by choice
I left I looked at my situation
I saw okay
I see what we did here
I see okay
okay slick move with the four kids here cause you think I'm stuck
I get it I get it
one of them is even disabled Whoo
okay
how am I gonna do this
I managed to move me thousands of miles away
from family so I'm alone
four kids one is disabled
cute you know
real cute position to be in
I didn't stay
I still was like
fuck this I don't care what is on the other side of this
I'm jumping cause I'm not gonna stay in this shit
not all of us get left
and I just want that to be represented in the conversation
because any woman that's in the position
I want her to know
I want other women who are in it
who are feeling those feelings
who know what I'm talking about to say
oh fuck if she could do it
maybe I could do it
because absolutely you can
so just wanted to bring that into the conversation
not all of us get left
some of us are single mom by choice